okay hello everyone welcome to a design
review meeting about incremental
language development for wolven language
and we have a number of topics today all
right first up we have find equational
proof and proof graph
all right so what this is about
is
uh
the story of
updating the output from find equational
proof
and
the
so i mean
the main thing here
is how do we make
the
some of these proof graphs more
beautiful and more graph usable
and how do we make the output from find
equational proof
more reusable
which i think is part of the story of
our whole multi-computation
uh
thing
but maybe we could start off with i
don't think we have anybody from design
here so i'm not sure quite what um
actually i have two questions so
um
uh
nick i think you heard that
i mean some part of this is axiom
to
to tautology which is the usual find
equation or proof story but i thought
you had a method now for going from
axiom
to theorem in at least many cases is
that true this is this is this is the
one up below
when you just apply here
so what does that mean so you can go so
there's the axiom
and then there's the theorem at the end
yeah but it also creates like an
additional axiom
which is another small green circle
there which is a tattoo
so
i see so it has to create
an additional axiom in order to turn the
thing around like this is that what
you're saying
yeah
can it always be turned around like this
well
maybe not but it depends on how what
actual proofs are there but in most of
the cases i think it is
let's see we have jonathan here and he
probably as the creator of find
equational proof he might have an
opinion about this
right i mean so what you're asking is
how how often can you rewrite proofs
that are done in the resolution format
in something more akin to second
calculus
and obviously the answer from logic is
sometimes but not always
but in the end something which is true
in one case will be true in the other is
that not the correct i mean in other
words they they are ultimately
equivalent
but
it's not obvious how complicated the
transformation is from one to the other
is that right
uh it's a little bit more subtle than
that
can you say
yeah so so so proofs uh in so
the relevant notion with regards to
resolution theory improving is not
logical equivalence it's
equisatisfiability
uh explain
so if you you're saying wait a minute so
normally
this is going to prove a tautology which
is of the form thing equals thing isn't
that right
yes
okay what what is equity satisfiability
well so as i say that the transformation
steps
in resolution theorem improving are not
guaranteed to get to preserve logical
equivalents that only have a guarantee
to preserve equal satisfiability which
is all you care about from the point of
view if they're improving so
two propositions are satisfiable if it's
the case that
you know if there exists a model for one
there exists a model for the other
okay
as opposed to what
as a as
which is what you said
and what's an example where they're
different
so
in general anything where you where you
introduce skolem variables is going to
like the scolamized form of an
expression is not going to be logically
equivalent to the original but it will
be equal satisfiable
okay
and
whereas if you're building up
constructively you're always
guaranteeing uh satisfied uh um you're
always guaranteeing logical equivalence
okay so and in general it's it's cleaner
to prove things by the resolution method
than it is to prove things kind of
constructively
but the resolution method is
fundamentally turning it into a
tautology is that true
yes
and
okay
i mean
the thing is that for other purposes
of you know find replace path and things
like that what we're interested in is
more
you know initial condition to final
state
rather than
this
case that is more specific i think to
theorem proving
of generating of tautology
does that make sense i mean that's
that's why i'm interested in replacement
a little bit different is when you go
from the left hand side to right hand
side
it's like well fair enough
okay but so
okay
look the okay
the first question is i mean the first
question is purely a cosmetics question
of
you know i think these these graphs look
kind of nice
um
and uh
um
there's a question of when if we give
more detail and we actually show the the
formulas
we could also show
the actual i mean
well now what's happening here so these
are
these are equations and these are events
that combine which have the property
that they
take two
lemmas in and produce one lemma out
right
and in this particular case the size of
the blob
is proportional to the leaf count or
something
of the
uh of the underlying expression
right
yep
okay but so one thing that's nice here
now in in the current find equation of
proof
formatting
we have dotted lines and we have solid
lines
and
i'm now forgetting what this i mean i
like the fact that this is very clearly
you know two lemmas come in one goes out
and that's kind of the
the story throughout this graph i hope i
think
um right
which is which is identical to the find
equational proof proof graphs okay so
i've had the additional information
about what the lemma was actually used
for was it used as an input or was it
used as a construct
what does that mean what does
what is the difference between those two
you can either take a lemma and apply a
rule to it in which case it's an input
or you can take a lemma and you can
generate a rule from it in which case
it's a construct
so in general a substitution lemma will
have one input and one construct inputs
are shown with solid lines constructs
with dashed lines
and constructs
sorry so what do you say about critical
parliament a critical pair lemma will
have two constructs because of course
for a critical parallel you want to show
an overlap between left-hand sides of
rules
and there's there's no input for a
critical pair lemma
okay but but but in find equational
proof as here there are two inputs for
every event
correct two inputs and one output for
every event
yes
and
you know part of the goal here
not necessarily
well okay yes no yes true
um
but in fine equal proof so one of the
things we're losing here is the
information about which
of the things coming into the the
substitution events which one
is
uh
which one is the sort of applied lemma
and which one in other words these are
not symmetrical
what we're now calling by substitution
or critical pair lemmas are symmetrical
the two inputs are symmetrical is that
correct
uh yes
what do you mean no they're not
symmetrical
i mean it doesn't matter which one is
which there's no
we can make the similar distinction by
just
like enumerating one of the input edges
as one of them can be dashed
it's like to indicate that it's a
construct
yeah but i don't understand what in the
case of by substitution aka critical
parallels
what
is it the case that the two expressions
enter symmetrically
they don't in the case of substitution
there is still like
a rule that you're acting on and the
rule that you're acting with
it's just with it's
you can make all circles read but you
still have this orientation this
distinction
i see
well
um
so in find equational proof let's look
at the corresponding defined equation of
proof here
um
oops we want to say
that comma proof golf
okay
so
there are a couple of differences here
i'm not sure whether we um i mean
one difference is that in this case
we're showing the intermediate
expressions
whereas in this case we're just showing
the events
that right
so for example in this case
that event
so where is that event here
uh
i mean i i'm a little bit confused so
that's
a dot a equals a
is
the output from that event is that
correct
and that's what that means yes
substitution number two yes
okay so then for example that would be
it's kind of weird why is substitution
number two
so hard to find here or maybe that's
because it was turned around in this
case
when i go on a voyage of
trying to find
they may be like change the
indices they might not match the
original one i'm not sure
okay
okay but the transformation i mean one
thing that's changed here is that the
intermediate expressions or intermediate
lemmas are explicitly shown as nodes in
this graph
which they're not in this case right
right
and
i mean at least in my effort to
understand this it's it's helpful to
have those intermediate lemmas there and
potentially to have
the um
you know this kind of thing
although that font is wrong but um
you know explicitly displaying i i mean
i wonder if there's anything we can do
you know in the sim in simpler cases
it's pretty nice to have these explicit
displays of the
lemmas that are produced
arguably
in one of these events this is where it
gets confusing and one of these events
we should be showing
you know what was the thing that what
was the actual change that was made we
have to have a representation of the
actual transformation as find equation
of proof does
am i making sense i mean so if i say
proof data set we should have that
representation there
yes
i mean the difficulty is the reusing the
stuff from here
is i mean you know
that's that's been the challenge but we
haven't had things which need to reuse
it
which we now do
so it's like how do we get out
the
right i mean
i mean this is perfectly nice but it has
i'm just you know the question is what
is the next step here in terms of
um
sorry i'm trying to understand this so
in this new representation
each new lemma is preceded by an event
it's not correct yes
so
yeah
each per lemma event is what we
represent
in the traditional form on the right
that is correct
yes and what's the advantage of
separating dilemma from the event
i don't know it's easier for i i mean
for me it's been easier to understand i
mean i'm not sure that and it maps more
closely onto our kind of token event
graph formalism
i see um but i mean we should provide
both right we should provide both um
and
i think also
uh
you know i think this graphical
just the graphics look a little bit
nicer than these two
yes that that i agree
um but jose to answer your question
graph i mean like graph theoretically
all you're doing is you're taking each
lemma node and you're splitting it into
two vertices one which has the first
which has out degree one and the second
which has degree one
and nothing else has changed
and i mean
one of the issues
you know
so in this graph
you know we're seeing perfectly nicely
in tool tips
yeah i'm not sure we can resolve this in
this meeting i think this relates to a
bunch of stuff about you know a
representation of computations
essentially what we're doing here you
know this is an example of where we're
representing a computation we're saying
you make this transformation we're
explaining
here
you know what is the position
in the input presumably at which this
substitution will be made
is that right
at which this rule will be applied from
left to right
is that correct jonathan
yep
okay
so i mean
the previous discussion
which part
you said that the proof graphs don't
have a representation of intermediate
lemmas and you also you and nick also
said that in critical parlors there's
still a distinction made between input
and construct
okay so it was my understanding there
wasn't such a distinction that critical
parliaments were symmetrical
is that not correct
well it it is correct but okay i i so
that's what i'm not understand okay so
fine fine fine okay so
but here what you're doing is you've got
dotted lines
that represent
the
uh
lemma input
the the the
operated operating with
part of the substitution is a dotted
line and the operating on part of the
solid line
correct right right
which is a nice convention and arguably
um
you know i mean
these graphs
are you know a huge step up from
anything that existed before but i think
we can do even better graphically
um
okay so
okay so that that's one issue is
probably we need two colors of two ways
to represent these edges here to
correspond to these dotted versus
non-dotted ones
um i'm not quite sure that dotting i
mean okay
and then
but the thing i was more saying is
you know
what we're doing here is we're it's the
same thing we've been discussing
for other purposes we are
we have
the um
uh
you know we're representing where a
replacement took place
am i making sense but which is which
you're doing here like this
but there's the more general problem if
we just have a find replace path or some
such other thing there's the how do we
report
where the replacement took place
you know in general how do we report
what was done
in this transformation that's that's
what some of the rest of our discussion
is supposed to be about i think we
should i'm not sure there's more to to
discuss here other than the graphics of
this which i think and i think in the
end what we're going to want
is a refresh of this graphical
appearance
and
then an additional i don't know what we
should call it
um
you know this graph here
we could call it a token event graph i
suppose
instead of a proof graph i don't know
anybody got any thoughts about that
and then
you know and then i think we're going to
want a version in which we do actually
display
in some form the actual
expressions as part of the proof graph
because you know traditional automated
theorem proving
people have not been that interested in
what's inside the proof
you know we're getting more interested
in what's inside the proof
um and
i think so
jonathan had also explained i mean so
jonathan has a
a different way of doing scolam
variables here with with that like
purple color if i remember correctly
is that right exactly yeah
and
um
and what jonathan was saying is that
this
this kind of untangling from axioms to
theorem
can be done
when they're not skollen variables was
that right is that it can be it can be
uniformly done in that case is that true
what i was saying is not quite that
strong it's just that so scolomization
is one place where i know that can fail
where it's it's known that
scotlandization does not preserve
logical equivalence but i believe there
are other cases in resolution theorem
proving work for which that's true as
well the the the point being that
resolution
unlike what you're describing which
would be more like sequent calculus uh
resolution theorem improving doesn't
claim to preserve logical equivalence it
only ever claims to preserve echo
satisfiability what does the word
resolution mean in the term resolution
they're improving so
as in reduction to a tautology to
resolve an expression is to reduce it to
a tautology
i see
and but
okay
uh
and whatever i mean so so
jonathan in your high-tech
proof-to-proof transformation theory
is that operating so that would operate
on
these graphs
using i mean you have a collection of
transformation rules
which are somehow
proof correctness preserving is that
correct
that's right
yeah
and
if i'm to think about that i mean
you know here
we're taking trees and we're
transforming them into other trees is
that true
whereas for proof to proof
transformation you have to transform a
graph into another graph
is that correct
right yeah exactly
and
and is it obvious
i mean is it is there a an obvious
minimal set of
sort of um uh proof preserving
transformations
it's reasonably obvious if you if you
play around with it i mean like so there
are some that are very obvious like
clearly you can if you have two
substitution lemmas and they're adjacent
adjacent along a solid edge then you can
merge them
because you know if a equals b
essentially because of transitivity of
equality
uh and similarly if if there are
substitutions and there's a there's a
for every one of these rules there's a
time reversal of it so you can there's
also a fission rule for substitution
numbers that lets you break them apart
that's essentially analogous to genson's
cut elimination lemma
um
and then you have other ones that again
become obvious when you start to think
about them hold on hold on hold on hold
on breaking apart substitution llama
is to say
you are
introducing another lemma
you're doing the substitution in two
pieces is that right
if you've got a substitution that says a
goes to b then you could replace it with
one that says a goes to c and c goes to
b and you still preserve proof
correctness
some c
and then there are similar ones like uh
if you've got a critical pair lemma with
um two substitution lemmas that come off
it then you can merge those into a
single critical pair lemma if you
combine their
dependencies in the right way
because if you've got a pair a b and
then you know a goes to a substitutes to
c and and b substitutes to d you can
replace that with a critical pair bd as
long as you as long as you handle the
you know the predecessors and successes
in the right way so have you implemented
this stuff
uh not in anything production grade only
in research code right now but i'm the
the plan is to have a function
repository entry that does uh you know
like we have the zx calculus graph
rewriter to just have a proof graphic
writer
and and what do you think i mean do you
think it is plausible that one can do a
a kind of i mean how does one know which
way is better so to speak you've got
these transformations
what is the
uh
how do you drive that so to speak so so
for the time being i've just been using
the old um
heuristic that we had for the zx
calculus
diagrammatic theorem improver just
choose the path that maximizes causal
edge density
um which gives you something that's a
bit like a gradient descent
where are the causal edges here
i mean there should be additionally
causal edges between these events right
i mean this is a
am i am i mistaken
you know within this event
there are pieces of this lemma that are
affected in pieces that are not
so we could draw on top of this graph we
could draw causal connections to
right
has that ever been done
well
yes
lines are telling you something about
the causality causal edges in the sense
of multi uh you know multi-wave system
calls ledgers a more fine-grained
version of that
okay but
but we could additionally
given the trees that exist at every at
every event
there is
every piece of every tree at every event
we could track its causality to other
events
well it gets slightly more complicated
with the case of critical pair lemmas
because the
expression to which the rules are being
applied in a critical polymer may not
necessarily be part of the proof graph
if that makes sense
so you'd have a notion of causality
that's quite dissimilar to notions of
causality that one has in conventional
multi-way systems
wait a minute this but this
in this picture
this node
that node and the one wherever this
comes from
those are exactly
the input to that
by substitution aka critical pair lemma
isn't aren't they
yes
so what are you saying about additional
pieces they're the constructs not the
inputs that's the key difference right
the only thing that you need
go ahead no please come on
okay the only thing that you need is
like
the
each event will contain a set of
positions that
was this event like acted on
so i can in the case of substitution is
just one single position where the
substitution happened in the case of
critical polymer is the position and all
the
variable
substitutions within the expression
because all the variables can be
affected
so it would be
a set of positions so just given this
set of positions for each event we can
just determine the causal structure
simply from those yes so nick that's
completely true in the case of
substitution lemmas that in that case
it's just the same as ordinary multi-way
causality the point i'm trying to make
is a more subtle one which is that
critical pair lemmas in produced by by
an equation or theorem prover involve
essentially the the input for a critical
player lemma does not necessarily have
to be an expression that exists in that
proof graph
you'll see that if you look at any proof
data set you'll see a matching cons so
you'll see that the sub pattern for a
critical parallel doesn't necessarily
have to be uh something that already
exists in the proof graph
well it's still part of some other
dilemma or action
no not necessarily
what do you mean it is because it's
like i i turn this
the spin apart i understand that it's
like
yeah
it should be
so i can't find the place pathworks
sorry
it turns all those critical polymers
apart in terms of positions
and reconstructs path
okay maybe maybe we need to get onto
other parts of the agenda we should
probably have set up a separate custom
meeting for this they're improving thing
um i mean there's more to discuss here
because
again
i mean
you know our
let's not get into this here let's put
this in the next multi-computation
meeting because this is this is about to
get really complicated as we start
talking about
yeah the relationship between this and
yeah let's let's not do this here so i
think we should move on and um uh
i know i've been asking this for a while
but is it possible to get added to those
to which to the multi-computation thing
sure you're very welcome to yes
absolutely
and and maybe um
my new
assistant infrastructure will help do
that
um yes somebody
who's some avery
you can you can do this yes
i got it
some or just feed it to the scheduling
queue
um
um only one minor comment before we
leave this so together with the proof
data sets and the proof graphs we also
had the proof functions and i think it's
there where we always had more problems
to represent this
by
uh substitution
so that that would be an important thing
to discuss too
yeah how does how is that done in fact
right now
i mean look
we don't have a way somehow somehow
there is a some sort of jump in the
argumentation when there is a critical
problem here
right but this is precisely the point i
was trying to make earlier so
a critical pair lemma if you have a
critical pair of the form x y
all you're doing is you're saying there
exists an expression
a common expression such that
application you know one rule
application yields x and there are you
know one rule application yields y from
some common expression z
it makes no claim as to whether that
common expression z actually exists in
the proof up to that point
there of course in most cases it does
but that isn't guaranteed
i don't understand this well enough but
this is an interesting i mean look at
this this is exactly showing us the kind
of thing that we need
for the representation of sort of the
steps in a computation
because this is you know we could have
something like this that just shows us
the evaluator running
and doing transformations
right what which
down value rule is being used and where
it's being used
right and this part works very well now
the thing is that when we write these
critical parameters the expression they
contain comes somehow out of the blue
and it would be nice to have a way of
of of incorporating how that was created
right
that's that's what what i exactly do for
the final base path
so
it works for both substitution and click
operations can we can we see a find
replace path just for a second can i do
that for this particular thing
um if it's not broken here
it's already integrity positive but it's
experimental yeah
so you're saying resource function of
find replace path
which is misnamed if i might say so
um which order does it take its
arguments in
the same order you can even defeat it
the proof object
okay okay all right fine
um
why is it grinding for so long does it
have to do a lot more work off to find
equational proof
well maybe just
uses a bunch of dependencies and it's
loading it
i see
okay but it's going to show us in the
end a path from here to there
yeah if it works
which it didn't in this case
okay
all right let's
let's tackle this a different time okay
all right i think we should go on to our
next
next topic unless unless anybody has
anything
about this right now um i mean i you
know look i do think we just need to get
a little bit of a design refresh for
these
and have them correspond to these and so
on
um and i know we also have this
mechanism what is it called is it
weighted proof graph
or is it proof it's like a weighted
proof graphic proof graph weighted i
can't
there you remember
yeah you see that's nice but so is this
i mean but they're both interesting
representations
uh
so we probably need to redo the property
list
to deal with that and okay just one
general knowledge question okay if you
look at other theorem proof so we've got
here an equation of theorem improver
and if i were to try to represent
okay two questions if i were to try to
represent something from the metamath
system something from lean something
from [ __ ]
what would they look like and do they
have a correspondence to this
anybody
nick can you say from go ahead jonathan
no no go for it
i was going to ask nick about metamath
to begin with
oh yeah it's it's
uh we already
i do have some token graph for the
metamount it's like a little bit
different because those substitutions
don't have just like a
target and
construct and
your rule
it can like make it's just a usual
substitution just replacement variables
so those events gonna have
like multi inputs just for each variable
in the expression
and i think that's
the only difference
okay
although they have they have they cannot
replace subtrees they can only replace
variable locations
um right
and on the graph you will see them but
it's interesting that that
you know that is more like our evaluator
just replacing is that right
just doing transformations on in which
uh patent variables are instanced
now okay so
talk about lean for example is there any
analogous graph for lean
there has to be
i think you can make it like for any
arbitrary
program
or code drawing
because it's just any substitution is
just function application so and
lean is highly functional so it's just a
bunch of functional applications so it
can turn it into
substitutions and so on and make a
similar graph
well but just so you're saying also the
execution of j random program
is also representable by something like
this except that most programs i mean
this is where it's this is where the
whole multi-computation story of whether
it's just a single sequence of
substitutions
so to speak or whether it has this
feature that it has
uh you know intermediate lemmas and so
on comes up
versus the whole question about whether
you're recursing through expressions and
so on it's it's complicated
any any any just final comments about
the relationship to other proof
assistants and their improving systems
i mean would we expect that in general
terms that we could take a proof
assistance
you know a proof represented in a proof
assistant and make a graph out of it
no children why not
fair enough all right okay let's move on
so um
jonathan you're welcome to stick around
or anybody who is here for fear
improving alone
is um
several people including jonathan might
be interested in the aware
kaido but let's let's see if we can
grind through conform dates quickly
so this is a relatively self-contained
function but it's come up a couple of
times um we were talking with
gosha and eduardo and some of the work
that they're doing for
the
uh
time series revamp and what we want to
have is a function where you can put
a clip
and
have some control over what you get out
um
i agree
the main focus i think is on date
objects which have the most parameters
but conceivably if you put in
a mix of different formats we could
spit back out date lists or absolute
times or date strings if you know so why
isn't this just data object of i mean
date object of each of these things
individually if i just map data object
over this with granularity month will i
get that result yeah you'll get the same
result
um okay so what's the
what's the difference between
that
and this so to speak
is it auto conforming things
so to speak so the single argument form
will auto conform granularity uh it can
also pick out
different parameters for calendar type
time zone time system date format etc
okay so which calendar gets to win
so by default
we look and see if there's a consistent
calendar if there is we keep it if not
then we need to have some heuristic
that's either most frequent or
defaults to our default calendar
right now the implementation i have
that's in prototype builds just defaults
to the gregorian calendar if you don't
think that's the right thing to do i
mean i think that's the sort of took
over the world over the last
300 and
400 whatever it is years yeah um
okay but now what about granularity do
you go to the the courses granularity or
what we currently go to the finest
granularity since it's the least
destructive so if you have years months
and days we will conform them to days
because we don't lose any extra
information
but you could obviously specify it or we
could do
i don't really like the idea of looking
at like the most common one
but that's another option for whatever
we want the heuristic to be
i mean i feel like if you're being
really rigorous you would do the least
specific one but
i would think so too
you know i can imagine dumb problems
though where it's like you know you have
all this data and then you have one data
point that's like granularity century
and then all of a sudden your data
disappears
yeah i was thinking you know i have a
bunch of historical figures i have their
birth dates you know
yeah so one of them is unknown yeah
that's a good point one of them is okay
but what should you do
it would be pretty
i don't know it would be pretty
confusing i mean i think it's kind of a
problem though if you have your
historical birth dates and one of them's
only known to the century and then all
of a sudden now it's in your data down
to the instant
like like this could lead to kind of
weird problems
right i mean that's part of the reason
that we have different granularities in
the first place is that we can have
dates of differing resolution but if
we're so let's go through the use case
for conform dates
so for example you want to do a time
series computation and you've got
you know
i don't know what you know democritus
whose date of birth is only known within
the decade or something
and what are you supposed to do in the
time series do we have anybody from the
time series group here
no
um
but but that's the question is what do
they want to do with that because i can
imagine that they can do something
different if you're trying to say
you know what was the total density of
philosophers alive at any given time in
history
and democritus
is unknown to within 20 years let's say
when he was born they're going to have
some way to deal with that in their time
series analysis
and it's probably
matters that that one is uncertain
rather than nailing democritus to a
particular year for example or we're
still puffing out everybody else
so that you know
we don't know when you know nietzsche
was born or something which we surely
know to the day
so maybe one question is just i mean
right i i would imagine that you know if
we do everything right then you should
never need this function because every
function that takes dates should take
any date and should kind of treat it
equally and and so on so
i'm not sure i mean it seems like this
would be a useful internal function but
i'm not sure when you when you should
ever use it you know user
we have confirmed audio on conform
what is images
yes so i think this is that's very
different
i mean
yeah
well i was just gonna say i mean i think
like conform images and perform audio
those are basically for machine learning
and they're just for making sure that
you know the dimensions and stuff are
all the same
there might be similar problems like
they are given in different color spaces
some providing more
bits another less what do they do
i'm not sure sure but i feel like i mean
but those are already doing pretty
destructive things i mean you know if
you call image resize on an image you're
already
you know
the result is only an approximation of
the original image you know no matter
what and again i think the only real use
for that is some case where you're
basically grinding up a whole bunch of
images together
you know
as in machine learning and some image
processing applications but but in both
those cases you don't really care about
the details i feel like dates though are
exact things
you know it matters whether it's you
know if it's off by a little bit and so
on so i i think it's a bit different
and also of course you know image
functions if you call image ad on two
images that have different dimensions
you get a weird result but if you call
you know subtract or date plus or you
know whatever on on two dates with
different calendars and so on then it
should work perfectly so i don't think
there's with images and audio there's
like a fundamental problem like if the
dimensions don't line up it's unclear
what to do but with dates it's totally
clear what to do
let's push back and ask the the time
series people to tell us what they want
this for
unless unless unless you have other
things
no i mean i think the the other benefit
of this is efficiency if you're
standardizing a bunch of dates if i have
dates that are in a bunch of different
time zones and maybe different calendars
or time systems we can basically batch
process and do all of the time zone
conversions all of the dates okay but i
don't really have a problem with that i
mean that seems perfectly sensible the
issue is with granularities okay yeah
granularity i think is the the case
that's a little more complicated to
figure out what the appropriate thing to
do is so i'll i'll check it we have a
meeting with goshen eduardo
fine and i could imagine a thing where
what one wants is something that says
uh you know
something like what the target
granularity should be
because i mean one issue is
by the time we're recording you know to
the minute
when julius caesar was born or something
you know it's just nonsense but one has
no idea right
and and yet
um
and i can imagine a situation in which
things are being stored at
instant precision
but where that's just goofy
right i mean
and where it'd be useful to be able to
do this so i mean that would be my take
is is time systems
um you know calendars yes those are all
worth conforming they lose no
information
yeah
um all right and push back and find out
what the time series folk need this for
okay
all right i want to i want to talk a
little bit about aware because we've
we've um i think it's a i mean we'll
well we can get to that but i'd like to
look at it where for a bit
what do people think of the name aware
is it insane or not
let me remind people what awareness
i'll come up with a better one i had a
big long list of them um
the uh
i mean
what it's doing is it is providing
uh
its most default case
is things like this
where
we are lexically looking inside
a pure function here
to find
what aspects
of
what aspects should be picked up
so you know one thing we're clearly
going to need
okay so what about the discovery
interface
of what is available at that place
so in other words you're inside a map
you're at level 17
what can you find out
so what i'm saying
how would we determine that because it's
only known at
uh
well it may not be only known at runtime
it might be known
at previously right the in other words
if if we ask the question
um and perhaps this is a code assistance
kind of thing
at this lexical position in my program
what what possible
like here i could imagine some kind of
auto complete mechanism which shows me
what set of properties i could request
there
in tech largest we do all so we have
this notation of arrow all and then it
provides an association with all the
properties and their values
sorry for which
take largest
list are all
yes now in this case when you just say
hash though
yeah
oh yeah you're probably right yes you're
right yes okay so so then what you're
saying then is um
uh here let me just
um
what you're saying is okay so hash alone
aware of hash
and then
that there
hash is is
um
hash is the full association
and which so your code could then say
you know it could pass that hash down to
some other function send it off
somewhere it could pull it apart
separately
right
now i mean much like confirming close we
might want a version of this i guess
this is the version that is non-lexical
you pass in hash and then it can be
taken apart anywhere else
that makes sense
in it actually you know it has to
construct the association if you just
say hash that's correct and so then you
could send it off i mean if what you had
written was aware of f of hash
and then your actual you know
examination of the thing happens in some
other function that is not lexically
connected that's all okay because it's
got to construct the thing to send it
off there anyway to create the hash
there
so then the idea would be
um that you know aware would have
in this case it would lexically find
things but again again we need the
discovery interface how does how do you
know what the properties are because
we've got lots of potential properties
that are
that can work
you know for example for example i i've
got another one here so for you know uh
map
related
is another property would be something
like how do you get those those things i
always forget
it's asterisk oh yeah right
um i should remember that okay so map
related we've also got things like um i
don't know what we want to call it
serial number or you know uh
you know what i'm saying which is ie
uh which
you know
you know what i have no idea what do you
mean by serial number uh what should we
call it it's it's the
okay if matt traversal index like what
index in the traversal order yes that is
that would be a way to say it traversal
index
i mean that's that's quite obscure too
but i mean the the but you understand it
etc you understand what i mean there
that is if this is which which iteration
number like like like you've called this
function
um
how many times have you called this
function how many times
has this function been called before
you see what i'm saying
as in it's it's you know it's the index
in the order that map hits this exactly
right
in the case of your map at level one is
it's the same thing as the index
yeah
um i have a hard time imagining
being interested in that i mean most of
us
i've
you know i've i've encountered
situations where i might actually want
that information i'm not sure i've ever
encountered a situation where i really
wanted to know that you have but you
have it it's it's for for example if you
want to give a unique index to
everything this is something that will
be useful
i've certainly wanted this since
pseudometa programming type situations
um but in any case i mean the the uh
i mean i think that the basic thing
though is that they're probably you know
they're probably a whole bunch of pretty
obscure keys that you know might be
useful once in a blue moon
and you know
ideally those should be free to add
yes quite i mean
it might be worth doing some i mean
right depending on what optimizations
we're gonna have in this might be worth
doing some benchmarks to see if like
there's a
you know if there's a significance
performance
hit to having to construct you know
you know every time we add one of these
keys if it's gonna be a bit of a problem
exactly yes but i mean so what go back
to the question at the top do we want
and meet a second the two argument form
and and i think the answer to that is
yes yeah i think the answer is yes as
well i think it's useful to have a two
argument form where we're affirmatively
saying for example if you're passing the
hatch don't want to be forced to use a
pure function of an association every
time
[Music]
well quite quite i mean in this case
look like in those first two cases you
don't even want the ampersand
it's just aware of index comma f slash
at that's correct
that's correct but but but that's the
pure index it's not going to get the
expression in that case so i mean the
map you know massive index i proposed
that if you don't have a list that it
gives that as an additional argument oh
that's a good idea
like mapping
yeah it's a good idea
but i suspect you should write that down
so that we don't forget it next time
yeah okay
okay so then then let's say
if
there's a tree meta applied page but i
haven't
made the page or anything for aware
okay
the second dog is um
not in a list
treat it
as
expression
comma
arg
right
yep
that's nice that's really quite nice
okay let's take a look here for one
second um just look at this
uh
[Music]
this was my meandering collection of
possible names
and names like sponge are not serious
what about giving or providing
or taking
taking definitely no
because take is a
you know
um
something about the act of giving
arguments
i think that's really obscure i mean i
think that this is going to be the case
you see most often in code
is it giving or receiving
yeah well
um
yeah and that's receiving absolutely
giving and what's doing the receiving
yeah
i think it's more that this is receiving
that supply
no because because because this is the
thing remember
what we really wanted to say is there's
a porous
membrane there's a there's a there's a
a collector
that is collecting things that this
thing here is having things absorbed for
it
from the environment
that can then go into this
why isn't it supplied
that's interesting
okay what would the what would the
sentence say
this would say something like
you know represents
okay so supplied of f
or supplied of x bar no it's probably a
funk
represents
a
function
for for which
situational variables
have been to which into which situation
to which
situational variables have been supplied
i do like the term what do people think
of the term situational variables
i i do like supplied and it's very close
to applied which we we have used for
other wrappers
fair enough i might use contextual
rather than situational
okay fair enough that's better
all right so then what about supply
i don't think that's right because it's
it's because it suggests it's going to
return something and do something
um
i'm just not i'm not totally sure the
use of past tense there is totally i
guess we like curry applied and things
like that i guess it's maybe consistent
right and i think supplied
of of the
of a function comma
you know index looks quite lovely
that seems that works well don't you
think
yep i forget last time i think we also
talked about whether the the arguments
should be at the beginning or the end
i know but with i'm convincing myself
with this
with um
ian's kind of
thing with the illusion of the you know
where this is going to be a second by
but by default this is going to be the
hash two it somehow feels better to come
second i think
even though
even though these things are ultimately
going to be
uh function arguments which in a sense
come first in the function declaration
there was that argument and there was
also the fact that if you write a longer
function it's a bit uh
it's a bit weirder like you have to find
isolated
yeah and it might be nice if also you
know if you say supplied a function of
blah blah and then you can see that well
my function takes three arguments and
i'm supplying three arguments and now i
can see what my function arguments you
know
what they correspond to and supply
because it's right there
that's reasonable enough that's
reasonable enough because then a not
unreasonable thing to do would be to say
supplied of
index
expression
level
and then you would say
x y z
function
blah blah blah
that's rather beautiful
what do people think of that
that reads all right to me
okay
all right well supplied is a decent name
i think
see how we feel about it it's less weird
than aware
definitely less
weird um
sander has made some comments here
commenting on
um
commenting on the discussion that we're
having before about um traversal index
yeah actually i'll tell you a very good
reason for using traversal index
it's for for progress monitoring
right
i mean and we also want things like you
know fraction complete
you know or elements
you know another thing would be
you know
elements
processed or something
another thing we probably want
which is
fraction complete would require
two passes through the expression
unless we happen to know unless we know
see because because we might know
in some cases like if it's if it's
mapping over a list
we trivially know
i mean we're perfectly so like if if
your level spec has a negative level you
are going to be forced to do a traversal
of the entire expression
but be that as it may
it's still i think it is no dishonor and
we're going to need to deal with that
case we're you know supplied with a get
this at all costs
versus if you happen to know it return
it
you know distinguish
contextual variables
that are naturally known
versus have to be mined
we don't really have an allegory an
analog of that anywhere else do we
but we certainly could have i mean that
concept of you know do you happen to
know it well you know like fraction
complete you could say if you happen to
know it you can display a percentage
otherwise sure barbara poll
that makes sense
i mean you must have something like that
in the progress monitoring framework
don't you
ketai or others can you comment on that
please
i'm sorry it was momentarily distracted
what was the question
the analog of things okay fraction
complete or total elements might be
trivial to determine by being naturally
known
or it might be something you have to
mine for i'm saying in the progress
monitoring framework you must know those
kinds of things
we i mean the the person who's
monitoring the progress
has the responsibility of supplying
those
so
um okay
right and so in in some cases
we do know right because
right we're doing an iteration over
something and so we just know ahead of
time
right but in other cases then
right like a download size if the web
server is nice enough to give us
the size of the file ahead of time great
we can say
this fraction complete but if it doesn't
we can just say we've downloaded this
much but we have no idea how much is
left yeah
yeah fine i mean there may be cases
where it is very cheap to determine the
total and others where it's not by the
way something we have not covered here
is um
aware or
or
or um
supplied in a rule
right something where
you know what i'm saying i mean is is
this do we expect this to just work i
think we talked about that
last time and it was it was there were
some issues
i don't remember exactly what it was
but we have notes from that but yes well
but but i think we need to make sure we
cover that case
um
but by the way maybe it's just a
slightly a point from a bit ago you know
i i did i did some i just did some tests
about you know uh if you if you
construct bigger associations you know
how long does it take and and you know
if you're mapping over something you
have to construct an association each
step and it does seem like
the time it takes does go up linearly
with the number of keys
which is slightly annoying right so so
if we add you know 25 random keys it
will be slower
well so if we add 25 random keys for the
case of hash so to speak
yeah yes only only for the case of hash
i mean assuming that we can have these
optimizations but yeah so the question
is is there any lazy way to do this
i mean we do know where on the stack the
thing was
is there any way we can crawl back up
the stack
i'm saying in other words if we pass
some kind of stack pointer
to the receiving function
is there any chance to go back and look
any thoughts on that i don't i don't
know what you mean did you just mean
like like you could you don't actually
have to construct the association for
that that's what i'm saying yes
you keep the stack pointer where you
made that call
and then if you ever need to know things
about the state of the world when that
call was made you somehow go back to
that position on the stack i feel like
that's not the issue i mean the problem
is more just the fact that
you know
if someone asks for hash
they're going to get an asso they're
going to get an expression with head
association etc
you know
unless we want to change how
associations are represented yeah right
okay there's a certain cost in print
making it so well we don't have the
notion of a lazy association basically
i don't know
rule delayed but that's different but
yeah
well even that might be i mean it's my
situation where you don't even know what
the keys are
right but it might be easy to make the
backbone without putting data in
it might be that we could make
a single backbone somehow i mean it
might be that with compiler technology
for example
um
we could make something where the
backbone is ready and has to be filled
in
but can we look for a second at this
rules case
because here
i mean we we need to inventory and maybe
this is something ian could look at um
and um
uh which functions can take
uh
sort of supplied
situational
contextual whatever we want to call it
uh
you know can have contextual variables
right so for example one thing i
wouldn't be certain about
let's let's take a function like um
so you know let's say other functions
okay so for example would
you know would outer take
could outer be
supplied
with and then it's a little bit
complicated because it's supplied with
index 1 and index 2.
see what i'm saying
the index is a list
yeah the indices of the
of the or or position one position two
[Music]
of the things right that are become the
arguments actually in this particular
case it may instead position one maybe
it's it i mean i would it should either
be if there's if it's always gonna be
two it could probably be left position
and right position or something but
otherwise it could just be indices and
then you know indices
positions or something
yes fair enough okay
but that's a special case for outer for
inner for example
it would be
more like
you know position well it will be like
like index one index two
um maybe there maybe there's a large
class of functions that act on like
expressions or trees somehow but
okay let me give you a more extreme it's
hard to imagine a limitation of what
supplied could do in any function
supply something about
well here's a case here's a case where
which we had before we had this notion
of a supplied value well a where value
but a supplied value would be
um something like sine x plus
and then something that depends on
uh
its
uh
you know elements processed or something
like that
how many evaluation count
you know something like this
i mean that's probably crazy but it's
just something to raise here
and i mean you know we could have the
notion of a supplied value
which would be something that
would pull itself from the environment
okay is this a possible thing that just
in an expression that one could say
something like
uh well this may be hopeless
you know like so can you open the uh
page for vertex shape function
it's not a happy
all
page
yep i'm interested in in the arguments
that are given to the
function grotesque where are they well
i'm i'm just saying those could be named
things that yes they could be so i i
guess i'm just saying this is just a
very broad concept
that could conceivably be used for
almost any domain specific thing no i
agree i think it's a useful general idea
which which has because they're things
that you might i mean this vertex shape
function
like a like a
x y coordinate for a center point is
just not going to make any sense in map
of course perfect sense in a vertex
shape function
right
but now the issue is a lot of things
where where you might provide a supplied
in the right-hand side of a star
function type option
right that's the notion there
where it's a thing that might be useful
for that function
like you know nearest function
might no that's a bad example um what's
a good example something in feature
space plot you know a um
uh feature extraction function or
something
would have both the main payload and
could potentially be supplied with other
things as well
like what's the total number of objects
that you're looking at those kinds of
things
i think it's a fairly general concept
which is good but i think you know our
original reason for introducing it
among other things has to do with
annotating
how
you know so running the position is
super common like we may even want like
a position applied specifically just for
that case
because we have map indexed and we don't
want indexed versions of everything
right so that's okay so there's a
possibility then a position applied
well we could have we could also have
index supplied
i agree it's awfully confusing that map
index takes the map index takes although
i have to say i think the use of map
index will just
plummet with these kinds of constructs
i mean i'd much prefer to use these
constructs rather than map indexed
um
by the way avery could you merge these
things back into the notes the stuff
about aware back into notes
into another multi-computation note
thing
yeah like number nine yeah for example
yes yes
um
okay we don't have much time here but if
there's anything here that we can just
look at quickly yeah i mean same as q is
pretty straightforward we have equal to
we don't have an operator form for same
q
maybe there's a case for it
it's relative because the one argument
form is is otherwise just returns true
yeah for singles and inputs it returns
true
which is was kind of stupid but but
well i think it has to do that's their
args yeah yeah i agree
yes
um
it's okay i mean
this is okay anybody object to this
and operate a form of same queue it
could be very useful i mean it's sort of
a shame that it has to be you know it
couldn't be
same two q because a lot of these other
ones are
two but i guess like greater and lesser
like greater than less than so
yeah i guess it's consistent
but it needs a cue right
as opposed to same as
well arguably it should be same q as
but that's a little funky well what
about same as
i mean the real problem is that equal is
equal and not equal q
right but it shouldn't be equal q
because it just sits there i mean it
can't be equal q because it's got this
right i guess
yeah
but what would there be a non-operated
form of same as
is there a non-operative form equal to
no
yeah
well then actually is there is there a
non-operator
is there a non-operator form of greater
than
or or is there an operator i'm wondering
why why do things like greater than
exist when i don't think greater can
take one argument
are you sure that greater can't take one
argument
not
uh
yeah see it's got that
that's why we had to do that okay
um by the way down on our live stream is
asking about the operator for
part why isn't that wait a minute what
arguably it's query
that's obscure
that's obscure i mean extract does
extract have an operative form
yes
oh jonathan is is
pointing out that there's a tally
production
slice
again though i mean
as pointed out before if you replace
every instance of slice there with query
it'll also work
um
would extract work actually
i don't know what um i mean you can use
span and extract specifications right
yes
and exactly
for some reason i never think of the
operative form of extract
i mean i have many times when i use
you know hash to ampersand
which i admit is shorter than extract
two
how what am i saying i don't mean that i
mean
of two
which could perfectly well be this
well i think same as is the thing we
should consider there
do we need an unsame us
probably
the same as is a little bit
ungrammatical though
like i'm saying from or something
it's kind of
yeah it's a bit weird
is unsame even grammatical
not really
well we should think about that i same
as seems like a winner but what on earth
is map level
map's a function of a data at a
specified level so this is basically
dealing with the operator form
it's a different operator form of map
right
yeah because you mean you can see in the
first example it's basically generating
a
curry function
and
there's an analog to query uh is the
final example there but it's a
it's maybe something that needs a little
more time to learn it needs more effort
yeah i mean i just doesn't seem like a
an obvious winner
so select itself does not have a level
spec in its current form
right
instead it has the much
i think much less useful thing of how
many things you want to return oh i
don't know i find that quite useful
i don't think i've ever used it
we'll compare this with cases
which takes a little speck yeah and then
and in
i've used that that count
i mean if i just don't want i want to
find one that satisfies something and i
don't want to go through the whole list
that's called select first
no you still want to do a select but you
want to specify level spec
no no no i know but this is the new
thing
right
yeah and it seems like in retrospect the
right thing would have been for it to
have the same argument structures cases
because it's easy to say level spec one
[Music]
but we could perfectly well say
i mean for example we could have a four
argument form select
no we could not that's
what we did
which is not precedent
say that again
uh i said for tree select we added a
fourth argument with the level spec
but i'm not saying that should be
precedent for this
right i mean it's just a little tragic
if if it has the same exact arguments i
know but
yeah that's awful
is it obvious what select does because
it's like you've shattered the structure
what do you return if you're not
returning the whole thing
so i'm saying
i think it's the same as mapping select
over it if you say selected level two
i'm not sure exactly if you did select
at like level two without braces around
it
if you know what i mean i'm not sure
what that would mean but because cases
is clear what it does because cases are
going to return a list of results
so i think does select preserve the head
is that
well that would be that that would be
the issue if that's the case i don't
know i think select is just if you
select it level two it's just mapping
the select over it
[Music]
now selected level n is just map of
selected level n minus one look this is
the issue
what
well that it preserves the head i mean
cases does not preserve the head
well what's the problem with the
preserving the hand i mean if you have a
list of lists that'll do exactly the
right thing
see that always just gives the list
yeah i i don't understand what the
problem is here i mean
what you want is you want select to you
know you give it some big deep structure
and then it returns a flat structure but
i'm saying i don't think that's what you
want i think what you want is for it to
retain as much structure as it can i
understand that if they're lists it's
okay you're just making more ragged
lists but let's say the things that
you're selecting into are functions that
have positional arguments and you just
shattered your positional argument
structure by doing a random select with
some criterion but that that's the case
with single argument select two
i mean i think select yes technically
works on non-list things but it's a bad
idea you know like you should it's
rarely useful yes i realize
right i think you're making a huge
sorry go ahead sorry i think there may
be an issue with preserving heads
since if you have a level spec you may
have things or sub-expressions
of other things that are getting
selected oh that's true too
that's true too whereas cases it doesn't
matter because cases you're just going
to unravel the thing and return all the
pieces
um
we should wrap up in a second here uh by
the way i just a
question we have a um
jonathan has been working on a category
theory framework and we're going to meet
about that and who here
who isn't in the obvious list wants to
be included in that discussion
that's a disappointing am i on that list
i'm not sure you were so you should be
um
okay
there's more enthusiasm than is
indicated by lack of lack of um
people clamoring to be part of that
maybe everyone's already on the list yes
we are in that list already yes okay
fair enough
um
uh
good all right
uh okay we should wrap up here first is
that nothing happening this friday or is
that is that something else
uh
i was added to a calendar event with you
with no title
uh there's one in my calendar with no
title as well so
okay i don't know what it is maybe it's
not that
i haven't a clue
someone wants us to talk on friday
it might be i don't know it's it's a
that's actually a new thing i've never
seen that before
uh okay
we're in a a
transitional phase in terms of handling
my calendar so
um
uh okay